Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to One Shot!
Now, I made a horrible error, I didn't close the game the last time that I played
I actually left it open for a long time so if you see...
...the guy saying he's wasted so much time because of me, that's not my fault, it's just that it's exactly my fault!
So, I'm back
"I don't think anyone else is noticing it, either..."
"Am I the only one who's seeing this?" I don't know, Niko.
I don't know, maybe I just kinda left you alone there for a long, long time and that wasn't my intention to do
Oh.
I forgot I need to move through this one.
Okay, so I really gotta figure out where I need to go, and...
...the only way I can think to go, and this guy is probably very angry
"I'm losing so much time...I'm not even timing it anymore..."
"I hate this..."
Okay, good!
Then you don't need to worry about me losing time, you just need to worry about you losing time
So what I'm gonna do is the only thing that I know left to do
Uh, which is backtrack. So I'm gonna go back a bit
I don't know where I'm going, ehh...
...instead of that. But I just know if I backtrack, then maybe I can start from the beginning and at least follow my steps...
Nevermind, I don't want to go back! I get it, Niko, I understand, you're...
You're very upset about the amount of time you've wasted in this endeavor, or that I've wasted of you for you
And hopefully, we can get somewhere that we need to go. Hello!
"Interesting book you've got there-" Oohhhhh!
"It is written in a language I do not recognize." Well what good does that do that?!
"Perhaps you should find a way to decipher it when you are at the library."
*different voice* "It may be of help-" I forgot what voice I did for this guy, I'm sorry!
Okay, but that's a good clue!
Because I know there's a library...
So maybe if I can decipher it, then maybe that's actually gonna help me do what I need to do
And if I remember, the library is over HYAAH(here)
And then down a HYAAWAY(Hallway), and then should be not too far for me to go with Niko here.
So, as soon as I can decipher this mystery here, maybe I can solve why all this is happening.
Hello? "Hey there."  "Hello." "You the messiah?" Oh, I know about this-  'Kay, thank you! Alright, K
So, there's gotta be a way to decipher this somehow.  'Cause this has gotta be the library right? This- this wouldn't NOT be the library right?
This looks like a frikin library right
I'm not a fool, this is uh... is a goddamn library right? It's a goddamn library!
Ohh! "You Need To Find a Way To Get To The Library On The Surface" Okay, so I still don't know exactly where I'm gonna go. But at least I should be able to.. do what I need to do.
So maybe I can start combining random bullshit in my inventory because maybe I have everything that I need and I just need to..
"..Magnets don't stick to aluminum"
"Weird Film"..
No, I ain't gonna combine it with nothin'
Oh!
What is this?
Where am I now- Ohhhhhhh, look at you. "There's a pair of scissors on the ground in a pile of hair"?
"I don't think anyone's using it anymore, so.."
How did I miss this?
I have no idea- I-I absolutely 100% missed this.
"Yeah! Maybe we can make a button out of this. I can cut a piece of the can and fold it into a rectangular shape, just like art and crafts."
"Huh... I don't think it's supposed to be this simple."
"How are we gonna connect it to the elevator?"
"Well, let's find out!"
There we go!
Now I got a god damn button! But the aluminum's...
Ahhhh
"What if I just fold the magnets under this edge?"
"Hmm...
It's holding together, if just barely."
"I hope it's good enough."
And then I can god damn
stick it with some god damn goosh damn taaape
That makes so much more sense than all the bullshit that I was doing.
Ah!
Okay.
I didn't even realize that room even frikin existed.
So, it's not entirely my fault, but
It is, again, entirely my fault
Because, after I started taking the short cut to the library or the "cafe" in there. Not really a library.
Then I sorta, just kinda forgot that that existed but now I need to go over to the tape dispenser to be able to put some tape on this bad boy over here.
Then finally fix this goddamn elevator- Then that shouldn't have taken me time at all. I was looking for a piece of the recipe that I didn't know existed.
I was trying to complete the puzzle without all the pieces.
I'm a big dumb doofus-do is what I'm trying to say.
"A tape dispenser. Oh, of course! I gotta tape it together or it might fall apart. Good thinking, Markiplier!" Hey!
I'm here to help you! As your God, I send my godly powers towards you to help you along your way.
Alright then, I did that I think anyway.
Maybe I should staple it just for good measure
Taped button needs some good staples on that?
No? Okay, alright we'll just take the tape and be on our way. I didn't need to waste...
...15 goddamn hours of 'Billy Boo' over there trying to get down to his job.
Well, hopefully, this is going to be okay 'cause this is one ram, shackled, shitty button if I ever saw one.
Well, let's try it!
"Let's hope this works..."
*static noises* Oh, that ain't good...
Okay...
"Reactivating elevator services..."
"Please input security code to continue."
"What? That's... never happened before."
"The... squares?"
"Huh?"
"You saw them right? They were on the door, and..."
"Oh, nah. The square stuff happens all the time. I meant the whole 'security code' thing."
"But then again, the elevator hasn't been this broken before..."
"Hmm... I guess we should go look for a code, Markiplier..."
Well, wouldn't you friken know it! 6-3-0-1-4! We have the code right here. Why would need we to go anymore? 6-3-0-1-4?
"Please input..." How 'bout a little 'ol 6-3-0-1-4.
♪Blada-Bing, Blida-Boopa!♪ Auhh!
Oh, wouldn't you know it! I had everything that I ever needed and it's all gone.
"What! It works!"
"I don't know what you did," kid, "but it actually works!
"Good job, kid. You're a genius, you know that?"
"Well, I had help from..." this God that talks to me inside my brain!
That always helps these situations!
"... Oh, right. The whole messiah business." Okay, yeah, sure...
"... Anyway, ready to go? I'll be up ahead."
Alright, I guess. This is going to be ok- *burps*- ay.
Fine by me!
"Oh! Thank you for holding the elevator door open for me, mister!"
"No prob, hop in."
Hop in, squirt! Come on! Hop on over here!
Alrighty then...
I guess we're gonna take a nice elevator ride down into the abyss.
Alright... nice awkward silence...
As your God, did you notice, Niko, that it's a little awkward in here!?
HAH!? You notice that!?
Whaa!? Okay, alright then...
"Sure is taking awhile..."
"M-hm!"
"Oh goodness gracious, I'm stuck in an elevator with the messiah and also literally God themself this is awkward."
"Oh, maybe we can chat to pass the time, then?"
"You heard me? I mean, sure..."
"Alright, Markiplier, should I..."
Ah!
Resume awkward silence! I doth decree it!
You shall resume!
It's how I think properly!
This pleases me!
Not a peep, you hear!
*fake coughs*
Did you say something!?
'Cause you better not have! I'd had been very mad and might've smited thee!
I could delete your files in a heartbeat!
Not hesitating! Alright good! Good, good job everybody. Good job being silent.
"Anyway, it was nice meeting you... uh..."
"Niko!"
"Right. See you around, kid. Gotta run now!"
I'm like sixteen hours late for my job.
"He seems in a hurry... I guess we should hurry too, Markiplier. People are counting on us!"
Well... "Let's go find that library!" Okay! Hello!
"BEEP BOOP!"
"Beep boop."
Okay... Nice conversation we had... Hello? You are looking so dapper.
"Sigh..."
"You alright?"
"Ah, the messiah. Perhaps this is a sign.
"Tell me, do you think you can fix the world with the sun?"
"Honestly, I don't know... I've been getting mixed messages..."
"I know... But what do YOU think?"
"I... think..." I don't think! The God in my head tells me what to think!
"... I think I should listen to Markiplier!" As you should!
Good job, messiah! You've been trained well!
"After all, Markiplier helped me get this far."
"I will take your faith for an answer, then"
"What do you mean by that?"
"It means whatever you think it means."
♪Mmmm me, me, me, me, brah, brah, brah, brah!♪  I'm so busy. Buseubrah.
Alright, fine then. Where am I heading off to? Where am I going?
Hope that plant is doing okay...
Hope maize is regrowing... I'm not gonna follow you sign! I got my own way to go! What the hell is this?
Hey...
"Oh, hey there."
"You have a lot of fish!"
There's one in your face!
"Yeah... I'm worried about them."
"Oh?"
"I heard something about how the square particle stuff just took out a major pipeline."
"I guess I should take advantage of the running water while I still can..."
Okay, alright then.
"Nope... not looking forward to that... water shortage."
Okay...
"It's a big fishtank!"
"... big fishtank!"
Uh, "... big fishtank!" Okay, good-bye.
Alright then...
Oh! Hello!
"EVENING NEWS! EVENING N-NEWS!
"ARE YOU HERE TO PURCHASE A COPY?"
"No? Newspapers are for grown-ups!"
"GROWN... UPS?"
As robot kid playing stereotype from the 1910s, I don't know any of the fuck your talking about!
"Yeah!"
"WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?"
"It means people who aren't kids!"
"KIDS?"
"... Er... aren't you a kid?"
"I'M A ROBOT."
"Right..."
Okay, alright then. Wait!
"HELLO, MESSIAH!"
"Hi!" What?
"DISTURBANCE WAS DETECTED FROM THE GROUND ACCESS ELEVATOR ON MAIN STREET!"
"HOWEVER, THE ISSUE QUICKLY RESOLVED ITSELF BEFORE INVESTIGATIONS COULD TAKE PLACE!"
"STRANGE SOUNDS HAVE BEEN REPORTED FROM THE SLUMS! THEIR SOURCE IS UNKNOWN."
"THESE SOUNDS HAVE BEEN DESCRIBED AS 'FAINT BLEATING' BY THE AREA'S RESIDENTS."
Oh...
A goat infestation...
"I AM NOT CERTAIN THIS IS EVENING. BUT MY LIGHT SENSORS ARE NOT DETECTING DAYLIGHT."
"I WILL ASSUME IT IS EVENING."
(stops yelling) Oh, yeah. You go, kid.
You go, kid. You keep going. You do what you gotta do. I understand.
I know that you know what you knewing. And I appreciate what you doing.
And that's good for everybody here... Hi! How's it going? My name's Markiplier.
"HELLO, PERSON. LIBRARY IS UP AHEAD."
"Thanks!"
Okay, so the library is right there then.
"When the world ends, would it be better if it was gone in an instant, or slowly fading away?"
"To be honest, I'd rather the former."
Alright, fine then... It's a little depressing, don'tcha think?
Okay, but if I take my book into this library, supposedly.... all of my mysterious are gonna be solved-ded.
And there's nothing on the outside. I was just doing a figure eight for my own entertainment and to please the God inside my brain!
Alright... Hello!
Is anybody here!? Translating a book!? Okay... How about you?
"What?!"
"Wh- I didn't say anything."
"Well stop staring at me then!"
"I was just looking at your book..."
"Yes. You are in a library. There's books. In the library."
"Um..."
"Go bug the chatty one upstairs."
"The Author's books cover a wide range of topics."
"It seems there are no subjects he does not write about."
"Quite the renaissance man, don't you think?"
"I guess so!"
"But he's been focusing on documenting the world as of late."
"Oh?"
"They say this city is the last bastion of civilization."
"Soon, these books may be the only thing we have to remember the rest of the world by."
"...ah."
That's sad.
"A pile of books on the ground."
"Books are neatly placed on the shelf."
Hello! Who are you?
"Oh hello! Do you need directions?"
"Let's see...this area is mostly historical records, uh, the reference section is downstairs, and, uh..."
"I'm not sure where the children's section is...sorry!"
"That's okay! I'm not really looking for books."
"Oh! Are you here to...look for the Author then?"
"...no?"
"Oh, that's good Er, I mean...that means you won't be disappointed!"
"I've been volunteering here for months, and I've never seen him, not even once!"
"He works with the head librarian on publishing, so you'd think he would at least show up every once in a while.
"But he doesn't?"
"Yeah, he seems kiiinda reclusive."
"...which is weird for a guy who supposedly travels the world."
"Maybe it's just around people..."
Okay the computer is off, but hopefully that is going to give me some disturbing clues later on...
Ah! Hello! Weird face!
"The Author is so cool!"
"I heard he can travel all over the world with a flying machine!"
"That's how he gathers materials for his books."
"Wow!"
Alright then, thank you. Hello.
"Um...What...are you doing...to that book?"
"Don't worry, these are my own books. That I wrote."
"I just pulled them off the shelves to modify them. I have to cross out some sections...most sections."
"How come?"
"Cuz otherwise they'll think I copied HIM."
"Him?"
"The Author! I mean, I really don't see the point in writing anything anymore."
"The Author is just gonna write about the same thing, and then everyone will love it!"
"And nobody's gonna remember the books that came out before his."
"Oh, uh..."
"I mean, I ain't hatin."
"I can see why people go nuts over his stuff. That guy's got major talent."
"But...it just...hurts, y'know?"
"It's never fun when people call you a copycat for something you wrote about first."
"I can see that...:
"People call me a cat all the time!"
"Even though I'm a person, and cats are pets."
"...and mousers."
"I sure hope people don't think I eat mice..."
"Heh, then I guess we're in the same boat, kiddo."
Alrighty then. Can you help me translate this book?
"Even then, it's still too similar."
"Just accept my fate."
"Well, I guess being called a cat isn't all that bad as long as people don't assume you eat mice."
Okay, then.
Alright, goodbye. I gotta find a way to translate this beyoooook.
"As a general rule, if a phosphor loses its glow entirely, it cannot be re-lit unless exposed to the sun."
"If the phosphor is merely dim, it may be possible to boost it through exposure to another phosphor of higher energy."
"But even so, the boosted phosphor will never return to its original brightness."
Okayyyy
"Blue phosphor. Out of the common phosphors, blue phosphor is of moderate levels of energy. It can exist in both organic and mineral forms."
*audio gets progressively faster* "The mineral form is most commonly found in the metallic sand of the Barrens."
"The organic form is most commonly found in phosphor shrimp and their secretions."
"Although the light emissions of the blue phosphor is powerful, it has what I would describe as a "self-conserving" properties...that is to say, the glow may not be constant."
"Most forms of the blue phosphor will stop glowing if left undisturbed for long periods of time."
"If using blue phosphor to power machines, a motor should be set at a baseline level of activity to ensure constant agitation of the phosphor."
"Alternatively, live phosphor shrimp can be used."
"Green phosphor. Out of the three common phosphors, green phosphor is of the highest energy."
"It is also the rarest of the common phosphors, as it can only be found in organic form."
"Known sources include the sap of phosphor trees, fireflies, and various mosses."
"Although this phosphor is present in the ubiquitous ground covering moss in the Glen, it is only in minute amounts and is almost impossible to concentrate."
"Green phosphor is ideal for industrial use. However, due to its relative scarcity and past overharvesting, there is currently no reliable source."
"Thankfully, at least locals of the Glen still have enough to get by."
"Red phosphor. Out of the common phosphors, red phosphor is of the lowest energy."
"It exists exclusively in mineral form and can only give light when in solution."
"The dilute red phosphor abundant in the city's water channels can be concentrated and induced with currents."
This can create an official high-energy state with greater luminosity."
"One major caveat is the phosphor in this supernaturated solution will precipitate out rather quickly."
"As soon as the phosphor re-crystalizes, it loses its glow permanently."
"If using supersaturated red phosphor as a power source, make sure there are proper facilities or services that can replace it frequently."
*pants*
Hahh...
Hi
"So, what do you think about the Author?"
I don't know, have you read his stuff yet? If not, you should
I'm trying.
I got a book. It's not translated.
A big book with black clover .
It's says "Emergence Of New Ecological Niches In A Post -Sun World-
Also known as seed shrimp in certain vernaculars due to the shape of their transparent coat...
...these aquatic invertebrates are the most abundant life form in the oceans surrounding the Barrens.
A nocturnal beetle with a vibrant glow.
Sometimes captured en masse and put in jars to be used as living lamps by the Glen's residents
This has inspired the now-common practice of using phosphor shrimps to do the same."
Oh good, the was shorter novel.
What a cliffhanger on that one.
Alright.
"The Author Publishes books at a highly accelerated almost inhuman pace."
Maybe it's a robot
"In fact, he has put out more books in one year than most authors do in lifetime."
"According to the librarian, there is still a large amount of material he has written, but not yet published."
"One cannot help but to wonder where  he can get much so done in so little time."
"I did the calculations, and the numbers simple do not add up."
"Maybe he...can stop time?"
"No such mechanism exist in this world."
"...is that actually possible in your home dimension?"
"Nah. I just saw it in a movie once..."
"About...superheroes and stuff."
"You're going through these pages pretty fast."
"Actually, it's mostly pictures."
"Oh."
"Yeah! The author doesn't only write books., but he also illustrates them"
"Sometimes he makes books out of only pictures."
"Nnneat."
Okay then.
Thank you for all that information.
Can I have any of your libraryyy carrddss?
Can you help me in this endeavor of mine. I'm in conundrum.
Well fine then, maybe I can talk to this guy and he'll able to help me.
Ah brings back memories, yeah.
Okay, fine then, you do your thing.
Ah, no one wants to help me, can you help me?
"I've tried to look for flying machine with my binoculars for ages."
"Never saw such a thing, though..."
You mean with your eyes or maybe I'm the one that's going crazy.
Yo, why am I seeing everybody has this way that they are?
Maybe that's unique.
Okay but either way that's the library, I can't get in there untill I get a library card.
So hopefully in the future there's going to be someone in the different direction that I could have gone...
...with the big arrows glowing that way, maybe there but I gonna try here first cause I'm right next to it.
And I'm lazy.
I expect everything to be handed to me.
"It's locked from the inside."
Well shit that wouldn't waste my goddamn time
I need not go down the way , hopefully Niko doesn't doubt my godly knowledge.
There's nothing really, tell me I'm a smart god.
I'm the smartest have...
Oh.
This looks dark dreary.
"Trash bin."
Trash bin.
Uh-oh!
"Markiplier! Did you see what happened?"
yeah?
"My vision went blank for a seccond... and then I saw something"
"...Like a really short dream"
"I wonder what that was about."
I dunno...
A bag of trash, gross.
[mumbled] I dunno... what's that?
Maybe you should worry about this, Neiko!
Alright... So imma go this way first, just because Imma hit all my targets first-
- and hopefully I won't forget about something cuz thats happened... m- In the past
Oo Boi
This izza POOZLE!
This is a long and winding POOZLE!
Wat is this...
"There's some big plastic disk"
"Looks like they're supposed to go in something?"
"Wait, Markiplier, are we really gonna take these with us?"
"But they look so heavy..."
"Alright..."
YA You carry those Neiko!
Oh!
"Hey! They're actually pretty light!"
Ok, good!
"It's a big book."
"The title says "understanding robots".
Can I get...
C- Can they tell me what taming is!?
... God! Damnit. Okay...
..." Empty coffee cups."..
"A framed photo of someone."...
"A lantern plant."...
Note...
"Thank you for working so hard, Mr. Lamplighter!"
Aw, thats so nice
Alrighty than
"A jar full of red glowing fluid."
Dictionaries...
"...Words are underlined"
"....*most* of the words are underlined."
Ok!
Weird, Someone obsessive lives there, that's good to know.
What's up heerea
Oo, where am I now?
Oh, hey!
Alright coffee sales man! I'm just gunna turn around and pretend like I never saw that,
-because that was a horrifying sight.
And I'm gunna go down here and see if there's anything I need to KNOW ABOUT.
...Before I carry on.
There is so many twists and tur-
ooO...
"Whoa! Markiplier? Did you see that fox just now?"
"It Ran behind the tree..."!
Uh?
is that the fox I've seen in my, dream?
"I'm sorry if you're looking for me."
"But i cannot talk to you."
"Not now..."
"Um..."
"But... Can you promise me something?"
Oh k
"If... you can find a way to return..."
"Please do."
Eh? "... What... Do you mean by that?"
"No reply"
Hello?
"There's no one here..."
*GASP*
Gone. Like a shadow in the night.
I have no idea what you want, mysterious fortune-telling fox!
Hello.
Whooa
Please do not approach!
Whu .
OKAY Well that's glitched out and weird.
Alright then
I'm sorry I can't help you!
I feel kinda bad about that, but hopefully,-
-You're gonna find a way to get  out of here soon.
Mmkay I'm  gonna go this way, cuz there was another way to go over here...
Righty quick what is this
Hello, "...Faded flyer."
Faded flyer,
Any more faded flyers?
Ah! Graffiti.
"A curious marking on the wall."
"Looks like a... ram...?"
Do I have anything that was ram-like
Ooh I got a lot of lenses
I GOT A FEATHER
Does that help me in this department?
Alright, okay.
Well there's a ram over there, so maybe if I bleat like a ram,
I'll be able to open the door and hopefully go, thro-oh, hey.
I"t's strangely warm in this room"
KITTIES!!!
I'M A CAAAT!
Nah, I mean Niko's a person. Not a cat.
There's a very, very distinct distinction there.
Oh a cat
Are you lost?
Me?
Do you wish to join us?
it was supposed to be such a breakthrough y'know?  I even based her on myself so I'll KNOW it works!
break...through?
We wanted to build a robot that acts like a person, thinks like a person...a robot that isn't bound by its own code.
Oh
But turns out, you can't really build something like that
Too many contradictions in the code...made her unstable
That was the only time I've ever seen a robot go rouge
Scariest day of my life, tell you what!
rouge?
But...she seemed so nice when we talked
even if she talked a little weird
Ah shes been repaired for sometime now
My friend was able to stabilize her volatile state through his own means
A miracle worker that...
After he was through she ended up turning out just like how I wanted
But damage was already done
...I gave up on her back then...we all did
I'm sure she realized that...and now she won't ever come back
She won't even answer my letters...
I'm sorry
Ah, sorry for rambling
Pleas hold onto that amber ok
I will
its so weird like its so weird in terms of like...
what it builds and what it thinks is possible it can build robots but it can't lie like its bizarre
hello
The luminescence index of liquid red phosphor decreased by a factor of 3.57% this past week
Alarming, to say the least... that's the sharpest decline I've seen, and the number is only increasing
We will have to further concentrate the phosphor now, for it to be any use
It's hard to believe, but there's a good chance this city could run out of light in as little as six months
...what are we going to do?
I'VE GOT THE SUN!
HURRAY ME I"M A HERO WITH A GOD IN MY HEAD!
I'm so sorry you have so little faith in me
It may help you to go one color at a time!
It's a big metal box with a robot in it
Beeb Boop this is the printer room,where machine parts are made also robots
It can also help to write down previous attempts.
I did it already Duh
I already know what i'm doing DUH don't tell me what to do DUH i've got a god in my head (weird Mark noise)
stop giving me advice UuUuHHH
If all else fails, wait for the puzzle to reset.
UuUUHH i already did it the hard one i'm a genius
(Mark Noise)
(more Mark noises)
euh
Alright then so hopefully we got the library card we just need to get a photo taken
and then hopefully we can put this on this bad boy with this glitter glue
and then, uh --
Oooh also, by the way, I have
Don't I have that weird free sample? Yeah, the water pill.
But I have a water pill and a tube of water.
So I put the pill in the water?
It dissolved really fast!
I've got medicated water!
I dunno what to do with that, but I got it!
Weird, huh?
Ok...
So there's gotta be -- there's gotta like um,
There's gotta be some sort of...
...thought to this.
Actually, yeah, I need to take a picture for reasons.
"Well, I got good news and bad news."
"...Good news is that the photo center is right behind me."
"...Bad news is... it doesn't work,
" Heh, you're catching on quick."
"After operations ended, the Barrens, this place got shut down."
"All of the engineers lost their jobs and became street vendors."
"Maybe Markiplier and I can figure it out from then!"
"That's good!"
"It would certainly help out people with expired IDs."
"Like me."
Ok then, so your street vendors HUH?
"You used to be one of the camera engineer right?"
"The camera?"
HU
"...Joyous memories. We went through thick and thin together."
"And by that I mean the concave lens did."
Hm, AH
uh-mhh-AH
OH
Concave one went through thick and thin,
*small gasp*
So concave is in between thick and thin
"Can you tell me how to fix the camera?"
"...Been awhile"
"I'm Pretty sure that the bulgy lens goes on one of the ends, but I forget which [one]."
Ok! through thick and thin huh?
Concave goes through thick and thin...
Bulgy on the ends,
Got it!
"Is there anything you remember about how to work the camera?"
Lemme see, "... When arranging the lenses, make sure that the thin lens is positioned between the two curved ones."
Thick and thin...
[Louder voice] Concave through thick and thin,
That might be enough to do it.
Concave THROUGH, thick and thin,
So- it's in between thick and thin
Oh no, wait!
It goes through thick and thin, so it might be on the side.
Thin in between the two curved ones...
Ok, I can get this.
Alright
"Yes, yes, certainly. The thick lens should be positioned to the left of both of the lenses."
Ok, So thick between the curved...
Concave through thick and thin...
So it's thick, concave, thin, other one.
Got it
Got it!
I think I got it
So, thhiick...
No, not that.
This!
Stop that
Thick which is there, concave-that, thin, Bap! Convex! Blap!
Curchunckles!
Hhheeyyy!! Loogat-dat I gotta get my picture taken. Oouh
Do I look good?
"Uh... cheese?"
*Camera shutter clicks*
FFUAYAHAA
(ignores dialog, screams, "I'M BLIND!")
I'M BLIIINND!
Blooby-doop.
Ok then, I got that, "It's a photo of me!"
"Are my eyes always this big?"
Yes.
Absolutely.
Neiko. You're eyes are freakishly big.And they light up my life.
OK it's working now! Hey it's working.
"Markiplier and I fixed the camera!" "Aw sweet!"
Alright then, we're gonna go down and maybe take a nap tu' this weird, heater guy.
That be, that be kinda CHILL, I think.
Pretty chill I, I guess
Where is he at? WHerE Is HE aT?
Uh ya down here.
Hey- Can I take a nap by you?
"So where did you find all your cats?"
(Puts on a drowsy voice)
["They found me on their own."]
["So I stay here now."]
(Back to norm voice) "Ah..."
"Well, it's good that you're not alone at least!"
"I met some robots in the other areas stationed all by themselves..."
"Felt kinda... Bad..."
(Talks chill) ["With robots, it is alright."
"We are not like people, we are typically unable to feel loneliness."]
(norm) "Right..."
"Well, you talk less like a robot then most other robots I've met!"
(again alters speech)  ["Maybe..."
"Not many people frequent this part of the ally, but there are a few." ]
["One of them even lives here."]
"I see..."
["You have been here for a while... "]
["Are you sure you do not wish to stay?"]
(His voice transitions)
"I'm good, thanks for offering though!"
Okay, Well, Apparently, Neiko's good. But I'm unfortunately out of time, which means I have to shut down the world on him
So,  thank you everybody! So much for watching! Hope your enjoying it this far,-
Likea I don't know how far we are from the tower, but we're gunna glue our library card and we're gunna glue our picture-
on that bad boy, get it into this library and decipher this book!
So thank you everybody so much for watching! And always I'll see YOU, in the next video, buh-bye!
*Outro jam ques*